Have you ever wondered
how some developers
build a great product and
business on Google Play?
My name is Serge Kassardjian.
I work on the Google Play team.
My focus is on apps and games
for our Android ecosystem.
I'm going to tell you how to
create a successful app in Play
and leverage unique
Android features to do so.
My team works with our partners
to build great experiences
for Android that get
their content distributed
to our large install base of
Android users around the world.
We want your business and brand
to succeed on Google Play.
So what will you learn here?
I will show you how to create
a successful app in Play
and leverage unique
Android features to do so.
There are a lot of great
ways to unlock value
and succeed as an
Android developer.
And I will help you
get started doing so.
I'm going to show you
how and why to do this,
demonstrating its importance
to your brand and business.
I'll also show you some
interesting Android related
facts as well product features
you may not be aware of.
Google Play is a great
place to grow your business,
especially if you
do it the right way.
The platform is
growing very quickly
as is our engaged
audience interacting
with the apps and
games in the store.
We currently have over
50 billion downloads,
with over 2 billion
downloads coming every month,
and we've paid out more than
4x as much money to developers
in 2013 as we did
compared to 2012.
Play also provides a unique
iterative environment
for our developers that
allows them to A/B test
using such features as
alpha and beta testing
and staged roll outs.
Further, developers can take
advantage of other form factors
that will drive engagement
through new channels
and touch points such as
tablets, wearables, and others.
This is an awesome way to drive
new use cases for your app that
previously were
not available when
you were on smartphones only.
Play will not only allow you to
leverage our gigantic audience,
but also take advantage
of new functionality
using your content.
We are living in an
increasingly global world,
and every business and app is
becoming an international one.
What is your strategy
across the globe?
Google Play and Android
is an opportunity
to unlock this through our
distribution and strengths
in various markets that are
large and growing quickly
as you can see here.
Partners such as
JackThreads and Noom
all use tools to grow
international numbers.
In fact, 2/3 of
all Play purchases
actually happen internationally.
And we strongly
encourage our developers
to take advantage of this.
This large
international community
includes 200 plus countries
that can download from the Play
store at 130 plus buyer markets.
To take advantage of
this big opportunity,
use our tools for
internationalization
and language translation to
help make shifting from country
to country and language
to language very easy.
Users will feel a lot
more attached to your app
if it feels familiar
and not so foreign.
Further, identify
countries that you are not
in that are potentially great
markets for Android and Play.
You can see unexpected
spikes of traffic
in countries that
you've activated,
and start focusing on
those markets, which
coincide with the big
markets for Android and Play.
The next thing to
look at is design.
I can't express the importance
of good visual design
and interaction patterns.
Design, design, design.
Make a strong Android Design.
It changes everything.
People love great looking apps.
It's your extension
of your brand.
Pure Android Design makes you
speak to the audience in a way
that they are used to
interacting with their device.
It will improve conversion
and bring your right content
to the front.
Great Design apps are
great performing apps.
So why and how does Design help?
Well, quality wins every time.
Our researchers have
shown that users
are willing to pay more
for better quality.
By using our Android
Design guidelines,
such as our standard action
bar, drawer, and tabs,
you can create an
environment that people
will spend more
and feel like it's
the primary channel
for your content.
As you can see here, as
your star rating improves,
so does consumer's
willingness to pay.
We see a dramatic increase
in monetization per user
as ratings move from
one to five stars.
Further, tablet optimization
emphasizes sizes quality
and purchases.
Compared to phones, we've
seen a 1.7 next purchase
rate on tablets.
Also, we continue to
make it much easier
for your customers to pay as we
increase our forms of payment.
For example, direct
carrier billing
is now available for
over 50% of Play users.
And don't forget, you can
respond to all your reviewers.
Talk to your audience to get
your ratings up and improve
your app.
As your audience sees
you interacting with them
and invested in
their needs, they'll
provide valuable
feedback and consider
changing their review
based on your changes.
Not only does this help
you improve your app,
but ultimately helps
improve the community
of interacting around your
app and their feelings
towards your company.
And don't forget--
sizing correctly
makes a big difference.
The smaller your app,
the less likely people
will uninstall it,
and more likely
they will to download it.
People look for this stuff.
They don't want apps
that eat up their memory
and drain their battery.
There are ways to
reduce these uninstalls.
Uninstalls will
ultimately hurt you
in how you appear in the
charts and search in the store.
Always try to avoid
these uninstalls.
And don't forget,
take advantage of all
of our fun, unique Android
features and best practices.
Standout icons catch
everyone's attention,
and Android icons
have a distinct style
that our users look for.
The app should be a silhouette
on a clear background
at a high definition, XXHDP.
Make sure yours is
optimized for devices
and is an effective
identifier of your app.
Make a great Play listing
that is very accurate
and includes screenshots
of both phone and tablets
as well as creating a great
video for this listing.
When you are marketing your
app, create a Google Play badge
on your materials
and deep link it
to your Play store
listing so your users can
find your app easily.
And finally, don't forget to
have some fun with your app
and engage your consumers in
new and exciting ways using
dynamic notifications,
live wallpapers,
and creative widgets.
Thank you for taking
the time to learn more
about some of the best
practices for apps and games
on Google Play.
We are excited to see the
new version of your app.
My name is Serge, and
I'm looking forward
to working with some
great app developers.